[Musik]
so schön und ruhig lag heil stadt schon
lange nicht mehr an seinem see
es ist da eine ruhe die fast unheimlich
ist
denn sonst drängt sie hier die massen
hallstatt steht für over to wissen wie
kaum ein ort in österreich seit chinesen
ihn als sehnsuchtsort entdeckten ab mai
sollten busse nur nach voranmeldung
parken
doch nun leere
die wenigen die kommen so erzählt es
reinhard kerschbaumer einigen
landsleuten unten auf der promenade
wollen gerade das sehen heißt ohne
asiaten ist jetzt die sehenswürdigkeit
unsere kultur städten sind zwei tagen
gefunden
wir sind zu besuchen wir genießen das
heißt wieder heil stadt ist und das
nicht touristen verändert wird doch die
geschlossen schilder erzielen auch vom
massiven schaden durch corona es macht
den bürgermeister alexander scheutz
keine freude dass autos nun leicht ins
zentrum kommen
wir haben circa 60 arbeitslose derzeit
voriges jahr um die zeit hatten wir
keinen haben viele in der kurzarbeit in
hallstatt 90 prozent arbeitsplätze im
ort hänge mit dem tourismus unmittelbar
zusammen
wir treffen mit gebotener distanz ein
paar wird ihnen fehlen die gäste der
gemeinde ihrer steuern
sie freuen sich auf die grenzöffnung im
juni um 19 internationale gäste nur das
bier warten natürlich auf die gleich
zwei deutschland zur kirche und zur
ungarn wird thomas pähtz bringt es auf
den punkt für seine ganze branche
im moment ist es einfach doppelspiele in
jeder hinsicht auch vom bankkonto
dass man auf die deutschen schon jetzt
wartet merkt man nirgends besser als
hier die vielen deutschen gäste im
weißen rössl am wolfgangsee unterhielten
im 50er jahre für peter alexander mit
gesang
heute suchen sie hier nach dem richtigen
abstand und peter ist hoteldirektorin in
fünfter generation
allein 75 prozent des umsatzes hier
machen die deutschen aus normalerweise
schippern längst dutzende über den see
bald darf das restaurant öffnen
zwei wochen später das hotel wenigstens
weiß sie nun dass die deutschen kommen
dürfen
das ist aber nur ein erster schritt ich
und selbstverständlich spielt der
deutsche gast in österreich eine ganz
ganz wichtige rolle und es werden
wahrscheinlich gehe ich davon aus auch
die österreicher sehr genau schauen
wohin sie auf urlaub fahren sie werden
zuerst mal zum wirken ihres vertrauens
wieder essen gehen ihre kernmannschaft
beschäftigt sie nun mit ausbesserungen
saisonkräfte vertröstet sie fördermittel
hat sie beantragen sie lobt die
regierung für das corona management aber
nun wird die zeit lang und das geld
knapp
noch ist es so wir haben keinen cent bis
jetzt von irgendwas gesehen
tirol die region für winter
massentourismus in der korona krise hat
es seinen ruf ruiniert in bergbahnen und
beim apres-ski steckten sich tausende an
auch selten war virus hotspot 250
schadenersatzklagen sechs wochen
quarantäne
der wirt und bauer jakob prantl steckt
das weg das frühe ende der wintersaison
nutzt der enkel zeit und für seine kühe
zumal er schon lang sagt training
tourismus ist mir eher als chance weil
man da sehr vieles auch ein bisschen
wieder zurück kommt darf die normalität
immer größer immer mehr lifte pisten
après ski dafür steht auch selten wird
nun alles anders
für das mega bauprojekt am gletscher ist
kein geld mehr da sagen sie hier und
auch dass ihnen die augen geöffnet
wurden
urlaub ist auch eine frage des
vertrauens darum wird nun der
bürgermeister
im rückblick ist sicher nicht alles rund
gelaufen
das werden wir auch knallhart
aufarbeiten das sind wir uns selbst
schuldig und natürlich auch den
betroffenen wird sich sollten also neu
erfinden mir fällt nichts ein was man im
süden neu erfinden könnte um einen
tourismus zu machen eine der für die
einheimische bevölkerung die die
lebensgrundlage bietet aufarbeitung und
weiter so ob der spagat hier gelingt
jakob antelmann chance ist soll und muss
ja weitergehen früher wurde er belächelt
erzählt er beim käse testen weil er
regionale es betont und sagt wachstum
habe grenzen
jetzt liegt er im trend und corona
verstärkt ihn doch welche art tourismus
in den bergen angeboten wird bestimmt
nicht allein der gastgeber jeder musste
dazu beitragen das heißt der gast das
heißt der unternehmer glaubt dass man
die schon handeln kann wenn jeder mit
vernommen wer soll ihnen nicht
voreinander angst haben
die deutschen sind in österreich in
diesem sommer noch mehr als sonst heiß
ersehnte gäste aber wie viele wirklich
kommen wollen ist noch nicht klar
[Musik]